Since I've already run git fetch,
my origin/master will
contain Sarah's changes, which I
can verify by running git status.
As expected, I see that my branch and
origin/master have diverged and
have one and one different commit each.
Now I'm ready to merge Sarah's
changes into my local master.
So, to do that, first I'll make sure
I have the master branch checked out.
And then I'll run git merge, and
the two branches I want to merge
are master and origin/master.
Like I expected, I got a merge conflict,
so I'll open the file and resolve it.
So I can see here's the original version
before either of us made changes.
Here are my changes
with onion power added,
and here is Sarah's version
with cumin removed.
I'll just take Sarah's version and
add onion powder to it.
Then I'll delete both of the other
versions and save my changes.
Finally, I'll let git know that
the conflict was resolved by
adding the chili recipe and committing.
As usual, when I merge,
Git creates an automatic commit
message for me, this time letting me
know that I've merged the
remote-tracking branch origin/master.
Since running git pull is the same as
running git fetch and then git merge,
I could have run git pull origin master
and the same thing would have happened.
If I run this now, then I can see
that master is already up-to-date,
which makes sense.
Now create a merged version
of your changes and
Sarah's changes by running either git
pull or both git fetch and git merge.
Then push the merged
version up to GitHub.
Once you're finished, run git status and
paste the output in this box.